hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to often what may be
the final part because I've been to
every zone I've done everything I've
double-checked with the comments known
as saying that I missed anything and
this is the last one it's got big red
letters it says the room seems pretty
final to me I've gotten all the items
I've been to every zone let me just
double check to make sure I got
everything again like it was just I got
the I got the grand chocolatier gran
diagonal grand spectral and grand finale
that's only the four items in the zero
through three zones I've got all my
dudes we're pretty levelled up let's do
this haha I'm oh well this doesn't seem
quite a bit more final but why is the
room all white and black alright Chapter
five rum uh wait a minute I may have
been missing out on something because I
don't remember there being any chapters
or a B for that matter well alright then
since we've already established that I'm
here to do good I hope you guys don't
mind as I very curious as to why I'm
here what I'm doing
well good Cheers my favorite tool for
beating away the evil what's the problem
what huh February eleventh Sunday
although I need to do the picture thing
again no okay
okay February 11 I'm gonna take a quick
picture this good me if I'm not mistaken
at the bottom of that poster it says
Zachary is the bad guy I don't know I
kind of suspected that because Zachary
is a bit of a douche but he's been
telling me it's a game the whole time
why am I here
Oh chairs you rearranged yourself Oh Oh
Zachary is a bad guy eh no hi so
sympathy lies I don't know that is I
don't like this place a lot
luckily Popeye's here today we played
together he offered me a comic he told
me that I was ill so I had to take pills
okay what else did Papa tell you oh I
don't think I'm gonna weigh huh what why
my back here did I do something wrong
oh oh I know March of the teddy bears oh
my god oh oh what are you Oh what are
you oh okay that's a lot of shiny bears
what we do about that Oh
okay-y oh you're not very tough are you
is this a lot of you so it's like just a
crap dammit now is my guy
there we go that guy is for those guys
this is gonna be easy with my friend
Oxnard and I remember his name haha why
am i fighting teddy ball so they were
all a singular unit I make sense in the
got low got loud up in here okay just
gonna keep moving cuz oh you seem sad
now you know what maybe it was new
necessary
you've got cheered hi hi how are you why
are you are you intend to marry you did
Jennifer its inanimate okay I don't like
these pills
nobody likes pills be a man oh hello
Leon
Oh Oh ghosty goos I'm gonna fight what
yeah not all of you I just want to see I
just want to see hello hi my name is aw
I didn't even scan the teddy bears I'm
an idiot
suppose ask anima ooh imprecise
ectoplasmic incarnation light weakness
against plastic good I guess let's just
get rid of him bunk thank you oh why did
everything turn into a children's
drawing I'm pretty sure this has to do
with that person that I saw after I beat
de Don in the second boss but I
mysteriously didn't see after the third
one the baby or whatever it was
not the nipple baby's butt I mean the
actual baby that I okay well this all
looks familiar
complaints just gonna be looping through
until I do something correctly I am
aren't I I am why or maybe I just need
to keep trying
here's what I am okay I'm doing some
wrong ah News I'm Ron do I need to kill
all of them I need to kill all of them
don't I aah aah
whoa whoa whoa wait a minute
all that did was put me somewhere whoo
maybe I need to go backwards
maybe that's the trick hey I did it I
solved the puzzle I'm a Joe Hoffa said
that we're going outside to play
tomorrow okay good hello Hey
our girls am i doing something right or
wrong chapter four has three friends
oh I'm going back I'm going backwards I
get it I'm going backwards because I
went backwards
let me guess date on the Phoenix and mr.
big man okay this looks normal
it's kind of like familiar but maybe I'm
just losing my mind which is a distinct
possibility uh I got a bad feeling about
this
hello mr. inanimate teddy bear wait a
minute that's different
nobody will read this it is stupid but
it looks like I've lived with it I don't
know what that says but I'm taking
another picture of this I ain't
forgetting nothing there we go got it
in my phone the door is open
what about this door okay that door is
open - what - sane okay well this looks
oddly not scribbly okay back to the
scribbles oh really okay I'll go here
the tall mr. Slendy man I didn't know
it's a Sunday man
oh it's a force at the slender huh oh
hey date on you the Slendy man I can't
go anywhere buddy or do I have to beat
the bosses again is this how this goes
finally wait finally somebody I know
that's not right hang on
finally somebody you would think that
there's no one left on earth anymore
finally anyway I'm glad to see you my
boy I got bitten boy a cow the pain is
hard to bear plus it's been 9 o'clock
for a war on there I don't like that at
all
what are you doing here by the way let's
ain't really a place for you ah but now
for gorse sake don't cry everything's
flying car call down here draw your
tears with my coat that is only the
beginning I can only get better from now
on how do you want to be a nice boy and
try to find something for me I like the
now what diet is since it's bad to die
for a war housing it ha ha ha okay well
I have a bunch of things in mind uh wait
oh okay all right that's just what you
said
but I mean I've got some calendars maybe
that's gonna help I don't know if that
helps
okay I'll just go over here now the bird
hm
you haven't seen the judge have you okay
why'd you have to kill Valerie Hey be
careful it is dangerous here you had
better not go near the cliff you could
fall and get hurt
take good care of yourself okay but what
if I what I can't fly like you so okay
bye
Oh your visit the big mister it's pretty
much again hi hey you down there come
here
mmm-hmm hey little one
I'm stuck can you help me get out of
here I suppose not if you go look for
someone to help me I'll bake you some
cakes they're gonna be delicious you'll
see and we'll tell each other jokes all
day long
go find help I beg you okay eyes I'll be
back
maybe the birds can help you but what's
down here room
I guess I'll good Oh what if I what
happens if I go back to the room I don't
know if there's gonna be any more
information on the wall you take the
calendar sheet okay but it was also
another day that's also something gonna
happen maybe I could ask the bird to
pull them out with their immense wing
Euler power and then something else will
happen that's good visit the tall
mystery stop doing the weirdo stuff wait
a minute what about these objects that I
have what is the point of the grand crap
if it doesn't do nothing can't do
nothing with it we got a picture of me
and Zachary here all right I say that's
a calendar piyo join it gimme that
I suppose it's not all that important
final I suppose it isn't that day
anymore anyways your mother don't worry
she'll come back soon
Jay's off to see the new world J someone
really important you know
watch these backs you revive all of this
everything will work again well
reconstruct everything slowly with a
man's now exhaustion shall stop us well
be the futures builders it's gonna make
great yes a wall ride potatoes together
I would really love nothing more than to
ride a Padano again because that was
awesome and
kind of not not that it's like not
boring me I mean just all this is just
have you ever written a Patel oh yes I
have back it's awesome
you'll see I know I wrote one yeah take
this in the mean time I don't know eat
it any more likely the Canada a book
with an unreadable title has been found
a Wednesday has been found I thought I
already had a Wednesday it's not a clock
wait that's not the voice anymore why
are the why are the window things weird
what is going you all right you're
looking happier than before that's good
don't worry about my I just need some
rest
okay by date on your nice guy nice guy
date on nice guy dude honors let's go
see what these guys have to say about
the things hi can you help this guy what
is that in your what is that in your
arms is that a book
what a big mister stuck in a hole calm
down I do not understand a bit of what
you are telling me if you hand me that
book I will agree to help your friend
okay so PAB well let me see what we can
do for that big mister okay haha hey
they did it yeah they saved him right
after I chopped his head off
well we're gonna ignore that okay voila
the big mister is free we will be
waiting for you in the cottage in the
west of the canyon meet us down there
and be careful not to fall hmm okay a
Saturday has been found I thought I
already had these just wanna hand them
hey mr. tall man let me go back to the
room let me go back and save because I
feel like it might be important okay big
mister Oh where'd you go big mr. big
mister did they throw you off the cannon
did they pick your eyeballs out if they
tear you're screwed off okay
that way it's called off coz a tour is
screwed off so the West is over here
is everyone partying in the house oh you
are ha ha thanks boy
I see we can count on you thanks for the
book in these times of misery it is a
very precious treasure haha what a
clever little Rosco we go where until
your mother arrives maybe we could keep
you company we can discuss about time
and the feet of our maybe we could even
dare to sketch out the maps of our
countries that'll soon be ours what do
you think little one a future where
every one of us will be the guardians of
universal happiness well every man will
have a job and actively participate to
maintain harmony where it will be
allowed to dream of a happier life at
any moment and where our sons can touch
our hope of course you do not understand
a lot of this grown-up talk you rather
should quickly forget our words the
first bright stars in the dark of the
world say go on out have fun benefit
from this new country which will soon be
reborn from this still warm ashes you
have no time to lose no need to listen
to the lyrical babble of three crazy
utopias a secret day has been found well
ain't that good for me what is the
secret day do uh oh oh that's very good
I'll put that on my body
hey does everyone have a day is there
some secret calm combination of days I
need the future only watch if we Troy
she adjusts arms and I efforts make it a
heaven on earth I promised you cakes and
I keep my promises you all be swimming
in an ocean of sweet soon no worry shall
reign in my kingdom for I shall wipe the
tears of the faces of my subjects ok
thanks guys I'm gonna go now because
apparently I'm reenacting the life of
the child who originally came before
this who is me maybe I don't know I
don't know what's going on I've no damn
idea I'm gonna just double check the
places again jump off the cliff no can't
do that don't want to fall gonna fall
into nothingness don't want to fall okay
he's gonna go back now
perfectly normal yeah room let's go back
to the room cuz that's the only place
that I want to be I got a bad feeling I
got a bad feeling why is the batter
still going through the what is the
batter doing this is completely outside
of his character of constantly wanting
to purify unless this is what he wants
to do I don't know what he was it oh I
don't know what I'm supposed to do but I
just got decked out again so that's good
going back to the room what do you want
from me everybody what do you want from
me what is what are you trying to tell
me first of all because I'm not sure I'm
understanding why I'm
err so then oh I didn't see that ah
going to mama I didn't see that before
ah maybe I should have gone to mama
hello mama Papa left I don't like him
anyways I hope you'll be back soon
I made three friends today the tall
mister told me that he'd take me on a
Padano ride and then we'd all work
together to build the world the little
bird told me that it'd show me the sky
and the clouds and that I wouldn't have
to be scared ever again the big mister
told me he'd make me cakes today was a
good day
please come back soon oh come on that's
so sad
what's going on why ever thought that
was Orville Oxnard and Oliver uh where
are they they're are they the guys uh
chapter say the world is in a window
what no no lies that's the main menu
it's a different song though what excuse
me choose to block a chub what hi huh
huh
what oh goodness gravy
Oh my brain hurts
okay the Centaur of the PO shall be the
mount of the one who seeks the exit what
excuse me take a little less acid and
then come back to me because holy hell
to NAV it can Adam it okay this is
normal I wanna go home
oh why something isn't working here what
do you mean something is okay yeah okay
what do you mean something isn't working
here the center of the bow shall point
to the exit has your life the Centaur of
the pole shall be the mount of the one
who seeks ya Jack what okay
okay so they're different oh oh oh sorry
didn't hurt that bad uh-oh
okay their computers over there I like
computers you ters are nice ooh and the
other day I'm gonna yeah okay got it uh
Papa gave me a music box today is your
Papa Zachary uh-huh uh-huh I'm trying to
understand
haha hi no uh-uh
hello how are you today
tell me a random number uh okay
hello that's absolutely correct
very well let's try another one
oh no no that's that in hooky what is
that hurting me
what was that just whoopee cushions
oh oh I got it ha ha ha ha ha ha
clever hey-oh
3 7 5 5 I got a you bastard come here
very long kinda what of course is it
what a die about Jean is right there
3 7 5 5 okay maybe there's another
random number out here somewhere
covered on the blood computer no ow ow
that hurts a lot okay it's gonna move on
alright hello hi what day is it today
oh I have a picture in my phone 18th of
March
yes that's it Bravo here take this as a
reward a mysterious symbol huh
Oh which says you can't I find metal in
the stomach of cattle at ah crap I did
bad didn't I damn and I'm in no I kiddin
where I didn't know his frog Damian
wasn't it without a pen tell where do
these books cannot be read at the
library I don't know oh my supposed to
know huh I don't even know what I picked
up with him looking ah the eighth color
yay uh-huh
alright color on a deck out alpha coz
he's the best hey hey
it's probably playing favorites but I
don't care at this point hello it's a
card have the impression that this is
important so I need to take a picture of
it is that what you're saying
got it alright oh good more blood can
you give me the secret code to the
warehouse
yes that's it Bravo
here take this is a reward a bleeding
symbol good okay I'm gonna go out and
try another one I guess because why not
I don't know what's going on no I picked
a bad one
I picked the wrong one
oh oh okay they're not gonna hurt me so
whispering Mitzvah why why is it a cage
hello my name is markiplier Oh why's
this a cage now oh boy oh boy oh boy
okay this panel seems to be able to
subside in the ground push it down okay
ah ah that's what this picture is for so
I need to crap I have an idea
yeah I did it I just copied the pattern
of those symbols on the walls on the P
symbols of the card I did it and I got a
number five eight six five got it I'm
good I'm the best I'm gonna win come
here you big Elson bastard all right
how'd she try five eight six five Bravo
that's perfect here take this you've
done well
Sagittarius card has been found wait
what cards let me go into other zones
whew maybe I can go through that door
now can't I
I don't know I don't know if I miss
anything probably I don't know what's
going on hi guys I don't know I don't
know anything that's going in if I'm
doing something horrible horribly wrong
you let me know and I will I didn't need
to do that all along with it all right
back to the upside down oh one oh yeah
it feels good this feels right on the
money
this feels right good I'm gonna take a
picture of that so I remember this quote
come on I got the Sanjit - okay oh I see
what's happening oh you flipped upside
down yeah oh and I got a code for this
one yeah three seven five five oh oh
jiggle with delight I've got you I've
got you I know exactly what's going on
here
I got it all
yes yeah today Papa gave me a comic but
I want to go out and play I hate this
place
I'm sure mom will pick me up okay that's
normal
save again I'm gonna save it could be
okay here we go
chapter two boxers adventures zombie
nerds going on adventures in my boxers
because that's basically my youtube
channel I play all my games with no
pants don't know how many times I need
to say that probably way too many okay
what do we got here
well another puzzle do you want to throw
my way huh oh not much else huh still
hang out of it okay good
it's an old comic read it nothing else
to do
yeah
I won beautiful day all Ville is
peaceful today lovely this will rule the
sweet blue color in the Wolfgang oh wait
a minute oh man
ha ha ha you're forgetting my diabolical
genius and my new invention
the cloning machine I feel ball fill
with clones of my evil self there's no
way to stop us now boxer and I've also
kidnap your girlfriend ah maybe it isn't
such a good a blue clean ball ville of
all the evil ball man clothes quick ok
what the hell aah woman I better hurry
bog borrow whoops here Jason what the
hell what does that even mean I have a
lot of help
ok ow hang on do I got aah
boom BAM okay Wow hey maybe I didn't
need to do that well the other guy just
I'll they just blew up why do I need to
do this
maybe I should just attack them cuz they
don't seem that tough
well bouquet apparently that attack hits
of all wow I'm oh yeah you know thing oh
yeah anslee
hey na na you wanna know clean your cat
ya know go worry about a pie oh man how
many more of these things do I have to
kill oh boy here comes some more oh god
I'm gonna run right past me
boom gone I mean this is charming and
all but I mean still goes along the same
vein if I have no idea what's going on
why did it get dark ah ah
why are you away from rocky f boxer Oh
ty go get away from me I may or may not
actually need to kill every single one
of these guys but it's the only thing
that I can control in the situation
right now so I'm gonna keep doing it
that's always it oh hi
there's a real invasion ah ha ha ha this
is your end boxer your buttocks Avenger
what stammers ah yeah you go get it
hello there you could go away from me
who's been doing the bomb in the past
I'm just hoping to does the bomb again
bomber
bomb him
there we go that's more like it
good Anya this task is even impossible
for a superhero you have no chance to
succeed hmm this is really stupid the
batter would say that are you ball man
no I'm not reading that why not
why don't you in bro today mom finally
picked me up Isaac we're down here just
go same game the end is near my friend I
believe what's floating behind you is
the final say box perhaps it would be
wise to record your progress one last
time wait a minute I didn't I don't want
to do that now that you told me to do
that you weirdo before you enter that
door and face the Queen alas the time
has come for you to spend the golden
fruits of your carnage right alright
then I thought I oh you do have more
stuff for me I can't exactly afford all
that so uh here's gonna have to go screw
yourself beasts vincit ki7 sit in
Victoria I don't know what that means
well uh here we go are you sure you want
to enter not anymore
I wanna go back to the nothingness ok
bye
here we go alright I'm sure here we go
chapter 1 the Queen
you got it weird moth background why did
I have to go through this story
backwards why oh here we go I'm ready
come on come on oh man this has been
such an adventure can't believe it's
almost coming to an end
the first thing she said was you are
finally here batter the wait for your
arrival has been a long one but your way
was in vain you will do not but raise
trouble here return home always keeping
his I see assurance the batter said who
is narrating me right now is that me
market blur that's what I did this here
is the cradle of my father your
Guardians are fallen you're now the
queen of a kingdom that no longer exists
surprised but not at all taken aback she
asked why have you destroyed the nation
that I have rebuilt the answer was
simple you've never been in this place
to do even the slightest thing your role
was to take care of him you've failed
your task now because of you I must
complete my sacred mission continually
withstanding the attacks that the
batterer had brought into the monotonous
dialog between them
the Queen called a spade a spade I have
done all this for him I truly wish for
my children to be happy we were so busy
preparing the birthday party that we
forgot who he was for this response
eradicated the patience of the Queen you
have ruined the carnival batter ok this
dialog is not started not making any
sense anymore I will not let you lay a
hand on the son we have brought into the
world
today you will fall okay
hike we okay here we go
it's gonna be fun I'm gonna analyze the
crappity and then I'm gonna get going
into the battle fader Aloha I should
probably write that name down
Vader Aloha Aloha means family family
means everyone dies oh wait Delta Sigma
and epsilon royal addons oh you got
things - I got things and they or Vil
Oliver an ox are way better than your
stupid whatever language name that is
how about this to them yeah they suck
look like our penis in the background
maybe a smash to do together you got a
straight up dawn going on there ooh
queenie got a dawn i just shut up and
fight have you filled your life Yuni
wait a minute and I have an idea I have
an idea
I have an idea no no no no no hang on I
have an idea have these things what I do
use them I do with this yeah I did
nothing
down you don't even know his first name
okay wow that hurt but you know what um
whatever
yeah half of your dong is down now it's
time to finish you off Queenie or I'll
get the other one for seconds no dessert
for you hi
I was promised a lot of cake so you
should yeah all your guys are town what
are you gonna do about that now Queenie
it's time to finish this tragedy because
that's what this is it's a damn tragedy
I am greatly disappointed oh your words
hurt but my bad hurts a lot worse than
that I'm gravely disappointed yeah you
said that I know you're disappointed in
me not gonna change the fact that I'm
gonna hit you in the face sorry I don't
usually hit women
oh wow holy crap that went by quickly
not really but kind of quickly
adversaries purified at her level 25
magic home run has been acquired that
sounds special that was very
irresponsible on her Park batter I even
made a big cake for the party tonight do
you want some coffee what my love what
Queen of the Flies it's time to join
your disciples it all went wrong time to
forget about it and dream sweet dreams
look he has your eyes who does they are
full of fear
what chapter zero the batter good okay
here we go
okay all right
hi Oh hmm
I'm here know what am i doing
no no no why no no no no no no no no no
no no no music box
oh oh oh
Hugo little boy
why his horrible was it point of getting
all the things that's what I was doing
some good Oh what did I do that I'm
scared of the dark from now on there
will be no more darkness okay what
pardon what huh oh I made it pure
I made it pure I made it all pure oh I
made it so up here oh I made it the
purest Oh Oh God
I've done so bad okay
oh boy stop right there you imposter
it's the judge huh I must say that I had
placed the blindest of confidences the
solidest of hopes that and the most
sincere belief in you we can all say
that I have erred to the bones
but the real betrayer is rather the one
who lies beyond the eye of the cat what
have you done markup ler I don't know
then what I could is the opaque mists of
the scenarist ik frame really your
excuse for killing wife and child you
have not purified this place you have
destroyed it eradicated it you have
immersed it into a
steen nothingness it's better like that
I should have not have lent you my hand
I should have detected the black flame
that consumed your soul from the
beginning markiplier join me expeed the
sins with me that we are guilty of by
preventing this monster from completing
his work don't do that I need you doing
in order to purify this world the time
has come to render your final and feudal
judgment what huh
what the judge special annex out pretty
cool the judge special hangs out really
cool which which one which one I'm gonna
go back and do the other one but I kinda
want to see the judge one right now
because I think that's the reason I can
get that is because of all the crap that
I got that choice was even though
pathetically useless I think the right
one well thank you judge and now better
taste our revanchist thirst for justice
of no avail wait what oh no oh that's
what I saw you guys are making fan art
of it I didn't know that actually what
he was so you're just painting him as a
monster he really was Oh judge you're
gonna his you're so dead I beat him up
too ungodly levels it's unreal okay that
didn't hurt you so
oh my hey you can't touch the judge yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah that's that tax
sounded pretty brutal but I'm just gonna
these it attacks all sound pretty brutal
but I don't know why this is happening
okay I'm just gonna
oh and he's gone you're demented crusade
ends here die batter with the eternal
souvenir of not having conducted your
sad scheme to its end it's too late
everything is lost I know but I prefer
this over your victory whoa okay uh hi
kitty
hence nothing remains except for our
regrets what okay that's sad No
yeah that's the end Braga
take this music ah but ah come on Oh all
that time I thought I was doing good I
thought I was doing good
hello kitty oh I thought I was doing
good I thought I was purifying the world
it seemed evil what was the point of
killing all those spectres what were the
spectres anyway
why why did that happen why I don't get
it because I make it is as I thought I
was a good person I thought I had a
choice I had did I have a choice I don't
think I had a choice
oh I don't know elevator choice oh I
don't feel good about my choices but now
the judge is all alone and heading back
home voices you mean me
you mean all those voices being me cuz I
did a lot of those but okay oh boy
I can't believe it's over this has been
such an adventure I've been taking my
time with this blazer but holy crap like
I always love when I get to the end of a
game and it like hits my heart that like
I've been on this grand adventure now
been doing this thing and especially
when it plays with you like that cuz
it's like you don't know what to believe
in anymore and you thought you were
doing right the entire game and then you
just turns out that you were on this
quest to purify into nothingness
I'm not sure how correct my theories are
but it makes sense that the batter is an
agent of the nothingness and was just
trying to return everything to chaos but
what does it even mean that the batter
in the Queen made a child why did the
why did he have to kill the kid could I
have not could I'm not oh they're just
the two endings it's just a two I don't
know anymore
my life is in shambles now okay time to
find the other ending whoa guys guys
guys I found this the grand brachial now
the only other things that say grand are
the items that I found off the boss is
why does he have this why what is that a
bizarre biz business nough Smith less
this is this is I've got for the vacuum
music box wait a minute
okay well now I've got five grand stuff
it's gotta be something else that I can
do I can go back to the nothingness but
there's got to be something else that I
can do the only other zone that isn't
pure white and pure is this one why is
this one why is this one so coloured
wouldn't have to say for yourself but oh
but you have the five elements if you
want I can give you a damn rare object
for him okay cool
the a sleep add the ultimate offensive
weapon of this game or the Aries card
which is though I have no idea what it's
good for perfectly unique as well
Aries card sounds important Aries card
that means I can go somewhere else right
right right am i right
ah gorgeous using new transit I use it
wisely the Aries card means I can go
somewhere that I need to go right ah
ah I found something you would be so
proud of me maybe I don't know what is
the Ares Cardew alright the Queen ease
down don't know where to use my Ares
card non-daily shirt okay I'll figure it
out I'll figure it out figure okay okay
okay okay okay
oh boy now I get to fight you again cuz
that's fun
okay huh for now and there'll be no more
darkness okay there's got to be a place
where I can use my Aries card it's gotta
be blue oh come on
where can I use it where can I go oh no
oh no oh I done bad okay so there are
still only two choices here my guess is
that now that I have this card if I pick
the judge ending again I'll get
something special but I'm here so I
might as well see the new one anyway
just in case is not that so let's go
with the batter official ending and then
I'll get back to it soon too bad for you
maka play you will die in control of
your evil marionette it's time for you
to wave goodbye to what little you have
left of your existence okay bring it on
judge yeah you got nothing on me
jeepers I'm Cooper I don't care if you
ripped apart the batter before I'm super
yeah
yeah oh yeah you can't can't touch this
oh yeah hurt so bad don't it Oh her so
bad the judge Pablo
feline Avenger the final boss oh oh
this it's over escaping from your
purpose is impossible
oh wow he's gone I feel good but what
about if I try to escape from my purpose
could I do that could I escape and give
me my purpose no probably not
okay that's a no the switch is currently
on flip the switch
oh boy
the switch is now on off oh oh okay I
figure I pretty much guess that now
whoa whoa
you have the Aries card you have won the
right to see the games true ending I
didn't need to do it again which is good
cuz I didn't want to do it again
whoa meanwhile in a parallel dimension
earthbound is this earthbound what are
the monkeys are those monkeys rat atom
rat atom rat atom we are the space Apes
known as Saiyans everything happened
just is we've foreseen now that the
world is completely white thanks to
marklar we can finally build our giant
vicious robot Factory and like that we
can't defeat our nemesis the flying
brains from Planet hours okay what what
okay I was commissioned by alien space
monkeys to oh you know what you know
what I'm not even gonna question it I'm
not even gonna question it the whole
game was weird up into that point so if
that's what the true ending really is
then there you go
space monkeys fire fighting flying brain
monster seems such a battle both logical
ending that I can do but either way I
think I got all the innings that I can
know about right now
so that was off this has been an amazing
game it was so much fun and I'm so glad
that so many of you joined me on this
adventure there was so much fan er like
more fan art for this game for me than
any other game I've ever done in the
past and among the sleep had a lot and
it had more than that so just thank you
guys who are so passionate about this
thank you guys who push me to finish it
and thank you guys who helped me along
the way you guys are all amazing
seriously couldn't have done this
without you this was an uninjured E and
um I'm blown away by it I never thought
that like a game like this would really
affect me that way
holy crap that was awesome but either
way there's a ton more games if you want
to keep watching after this what
hour-long episode if you would still
want to keep watching there's more
videos in the description below just
thank you guys so much for watching
watching every day we're watching
whenever you can
you're the best fans in the world and I
love you so thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
you